[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 les titres de ce
mercredi 22 novembre un nouveau
mouvement politique dans les yvelines
objectif france a lancé hier à
versailles sa section dans le
département ces responsables et
adhérents ne se reconnaissent pas dans
le parti des républicains
il souhaite construire une droite forte
pour faire opposition au gouvernement
les précisions dans cette édition
c'était une promesse d' emmanuel macron
la police de sécurité du quotidien as va
être testée prochainement une grande
concertation a été lancée dans les
yvelines de nouvelles forces de l'ordre
dont le contour et l'émission restent
encore floues nous tentons d'y voir plus
clair chronique à suivre et puis c'est
l'anti black friday le green friday
démarre demain a pour trois jours
initiée par l'association envie à
l'action vise notamment à sensibiliser
aux alternatives à la consommation
classique pour en parler en plateau eric
gastineau directeur du magasin envie à
trappes
on débute ce journal avec ces images un
arbre des droits de l'enfant a été mise
en terre cet après midi dans le parc de
la mairie à montigny le bretonneux
plantation symbolique deux jours après
le 28e anniversaire de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
montigny le bretonneux d'ailleurs
labellisée ville amie des enfants par
l'unicef depuis cette année pendant la
cérémonie et des jeunes ont lu les 54
articles de ce texte adopté par l'onu
propos recueillis par aurélien oms
c'est l'unicef qui proposait de
participer à cette action qui existe
depuis la signature de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
et comme la ville de montigny et
un label ville amie des enfants et
les structures d'accueil enfants et
jeunes ont souhaité participer proposer
des animations toute la semaine les
droits à l'éducation les droits à la
santé qu'on doit toujours réaffirmée
puisque dans certaines parties du monde
ces droits sont encore pas toujours
respectée et vous pouvez soutenir la
cause des droits de l'enfant faisant un
don à l'unicef sur le site internet qui
s'affiche une volonté rebondir après
l'échec de la droite aux élections
présidentielles le mouvement politique
objectif france a désormais sa
déclinaison dans les yvelines à
lancement de la section départementale
hier à versailles en présence du
président du parti
rafik smati il regroupe des déçus des
républicains mais aussi des militants
souhaitant construire une opposition
forte au gouvernement est les détails
avec nicolas kirillovitch et les arrêts
ch objectif france est un mouvement
nouveau rafik smati à une colonne
vertébrale idéologique de droite qui est
forte et qui en même temps est capable
de porter des projets aux nouveaux comme
l'écologie par exemple où l'intelligence
artificielle objectif france ce
mouvement politique ne vous dit peut
être rien pourtant il existe depuis 2014
à sa tête rafik smati chefs
d'entreprises français de 41 ans
il réunissait mardi soir à versailles
les adhérents et les curieux pour le
lancement du mouvement dans les yvelines
quel est notre objectif la france on est
un mouvement politique on est on a envie
de tourner la page de 30 ans de lâcheté
de renoncement de d'abandon idéologique
nous sommes un mouvement de nouvelle
génération qui rassemblant plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes en
france qui commence à avoir un ancrage
territorial fort l'envi de donner un
nouveau souffle au visage politique
français est un point fondamental
d'objectifs france le mouvement
libéral-conservateur cherche à associer
des valeurs modernes et écologiques
nous parlons de ce monde en mutation de
cette de ce tsunami technologique qui
est devant nous qui est comparable à une
seconde renaissance et qui va tout
redéfinir notre rapport à l'économie
notre rapport au travail
notre rapport à la santé notre rapport
au vivant et nous voulons projeter la
france dans ce monde parce que si nous
ne montons pas dans ce train là eh bien
il va y avoir un très grand nombre de
deux naufragés clairement en opposition
avec le président macron et son
mouvement en marche
rafik smati évoque son souhait de
rassembler la droite
notre objectif n'est pas de créer un
petit mouvement qui se situera à la
périphérie du système et qui fera trois
ou quatre pour cent donc nous ferons ce
qu'il faut pour être au centre de la
recomposition de la droite
le mouvement compte aujourd'hui près de
33 mille adhérents dans toute la france
et 350 dans les yvelines un département
qui reste encore à convaincre politique
toujours il l'avait annoncé au moment de
son élection à la tête de saint quentin
en yvelines jean michel fourgous n'est
officiellement plus conseiller
départemental du canton de trappes
le maire les républicains d'elancourt a
remis sa démission promesse de l'édile
pour pouvoir se consacrer pleinement à
son nouveau rôle de président
d'agglomération
c'est donc son suppléant nicollin
dainville qui a siègera désormais au
conseil départemental des yvelines
l'élu d'opposition à la verrière sera
l'invité de nicolas kirillovitch
vendredi dans le 7-8 l'hebdo autres
nicole avec moi plateau c'est nicolas
landry bonsoir bon sens de la rédaction
de tv 78 alors c'est une réforme qui
figurait au programme des manuels macron
pendant la campagne présidentielle la
police de sécurité du quotidien le
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb a
lancé le 28 octobre dernier une grande
concertation sur le sujet
ce positif qui rappelle celui de la
police de proximité instaurée lors du
gouvernement jospin à la fin des années
90 nicolas landry à quoi pourrait
ressembler cette police de sécurité du
quotidien et bien grégory c'est une
police aux ambitions renouvelées
respecter sur mesure connecté et
partenariale voilà les cinq priorités
affichées par le ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est un peu flou tout de même nicolas
rey rien n'est finalement défini
effectivement grégory rien n'est encore
concret nous sommes actuellement dans
une phase de définition du dispositif
une définition qui passe à travers des
concertations comme vous le voyez à
l'image c'était jeudi dernier le préfet
des yvelines a réuni les policiers les
gendarmes les élus locaux et des
représentants d'associations pour
échanger et connaître leurs attentes
pendant un mois six réunions de ce type
vont se tenir dans les différents
arrondissements des yvelines objectif
connaître les besoins de la population
et des forces de l'ordre
écoutez serge morvan le préfet des
yvelines et la police de sécurité du
quotidien mais évidemment il faut
qu'elle le soit
déconcentré aussi il faut que son action
soit le plus proche possible du
quotidien et le quotidien c'est pas le
même suivant vous habitez y compris dans
les yvelines
donc effectivement pour cela il faut une
définition la plus proche possible de la
population des actions à mettre en
oeuvre pour répondre à leur sentiment
d'insécurité et à leurs besoins de
sécurité
colas soir les forces de l'ordre les
policiers nationaux et les ans les
gendarmes pardon ont déjà reçu des
questionnaires anonymes différentes
questions sur les conditions de travail
les améliorations que pourrait apporter
l'état sur les dispositifs déjà en place
ou encore l'émission de la future police
de sécurité du quotidien autres unités
concernées par cette réforme
évidemment les policiers municipaux
chaque gendarme est écoutée on va faire
des propositions et on va proposer au
niveau du département je doit proposer
des expérimentations au niveau national
c'est une nouvelle démarche qui par ses
du de la base vers le national et qui
donne plus de marge de manoeuvre en
effet aux échelons locaux de
commandement que sont les départements
voir les commandes compagnies qui sont
dans les arrondissements l on a besoin
aussi de l'appui de la police nationale
pour un certain moment compléter nos
prérogatives qui parfois ont des limites
surtout sur la sanction des de certaines
infractions
d'où l'intérêt de la police de sécurité
du quotidien qui va appuyer nos actions
et intervenir en renfort partenariat
partenariat qui est déjà développé mais
qui sera très certainement renforcé et
sûrement très efficace autres acteurs
présents lors de cette concertation le
procureur de la république de versailles
dans les clous un volet judiciaire
important dans cette réforme notamment
dans la définition des missions de la
police de sécurité du quotidien avec en
point d'orgue bien sûr l'efficacité des
relations entre la police et la justice
cette concertation est une excellente
chose puisque les besoins de sécurité
varie les les infractions change de
nature change d'expression et il importe
de s'adapter sans arrêt pour notre part
nous prendront part à cette concertation
en proposant des solutions de
simplification de la procédure pénale
dans cet esprit là nous continuerons à
faciliter le travail de cette nouvelle
police du quotidien comme nous avons
commencé à faciliter le travail de la
police en général et la gendarmerie en
général les résultats de cette
concertation doivent être rendues par le
préfet le 15 décembre prochain au
ministère de l'intérieur
les premières expérimentations devraient
être lancés début 2018 dans plusieurs
communes d'après certaines rumeurs
trappe et aulnay sous bois seraient des
villes candidates
merci nicolas landry à la fin d'année
approchent les cadeaux à faire les fêtes
a préparé vous êtes également sollicité
à de nombreuses reprises pour acheter
des calendriers pompiers facteurs
éboueurs et mais gare aux arnaques
sentir l'école a convié ses seniors à
une réunion de prévention avec quelques
conseils à adopter marylène iapichino
repérer les fausses cartes
resté discret sur ce qu on possède
installait un entrebâilleur des conseils
pratiques de la direction départementale
de la sécurité publique des yvelines une
soixantaine de personnes s'est déplacée
à la maison des familles de saint cyr
l'école mardi soir
le but de l'intervention faire des
cibles préférées des arnaqueurs des
personnes averties d'autant plus en
cette période de fin d'année et sa
traditionnelle vente de calendriers à
domicile donc les facteurs les pompiers
en général on les connaît puisant des
calendriers particulier qu'on reconnaît
on se méfie quand même parce qu'on sait
jamais et ensuite vous avez bien on a
les éboueurs on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure des gens qui se font passer pour
des associations caritatives et qui
veulent vendre des calendriers et là la
ligne de conduite se dire ok je veux
donner aux éboueurs donc je donne au
moment où ils ramassent les poubelles et
si je veux donner une association
caritative
je ferai un don soit en ligne sur
internet je ferai un donjon vers un
chèque à l'association dernières
révisions pour les seniors qui ont pris
note de tous ces conseils on nous a
montré des cartes professionnelles de
police qui sont nouvelles qui sont pas
du tout celles de julie lescaut ou de
houe de corinne touzet plus d' arnaque
possible à saint-cyr-l'ecole maintenant
que la population est averti et si
jamais vous avez des doutes
la police rappelle de ne pas hésiter à
faire le 17
le dernier week-end de novembre synonyme
de black friday opération commerciale
qui propose des promotions dans les
boutiques et vous incite à acheter et
bien vous devrez noté dorénavant dans
vos agendas cette date un autre
événement c'est le green friday bonsoir
erika gastineau bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur du magasin envie attrape alors
le réseau envie lance au niveau national
ce green friday c'est de demain à samedi
c'est un anti black friday finalement
puisque il sensibilise aux alternatives
à la consommation classique et valorise
aussi une démarche autour du réemploi
des objets des animations vont se tenir
à trappes ou assad en un instant par
l'ont peut-être déjà d'abord de l'esprit
d'envy envies ses 30 ans de
lutte contre le gaspillage oui en vie
est un pionner de l'économie circulaire
ça fait ça fait plus de trente ans quand
vie s'est lancé dans la rénovation
d'appareils électroménagers et la
revente a garanti d'appareils qui
étaient destinés à devenir des déchets
et donc qu'il retrouve une deuxième vie
donc aujourd'hui le réseau envie c'est
une cinquantaine d'entreprises dans
toute la france et qui rénovent 94 mille
appareils par an c'est pas rien dans l
eau déchets évités chaque année 94 mille
appareils qui sont sauvées la
destruction donner une deuxième vie à
ces appareils aussi une mission
d'insertion professionnelle pour envie
c'est même le coeur du métier c'est la
raison d'être du réseau envie c'est
l'insertion par l'activité économique
dans nos ateliers ce sont des gens qui
étaient en rupture avec le monde du
travail que l'on remet dans l'emploi au
sein de nos entreprises d'insertion avec
pour vocation de retrouver un emploi
durable
à la sortie de la parcours chez envie
alors on revient à ce green friday
pourquoi proposer finalement de contrer
ce black friday qu'est ce qui ne tourne
pas rond dans cette opération
vous l'avez bien résumé ses grilles du
trail des versus black friday le braque
dakar et des six essais de grand-messe
consumériste qui nous vient des états
unis qui est pas très intéressante
d'ailleurs pour consommateurs une étude
j'essaie que choisir montré que le
gardien au prix environ 2% impôts
consommateurs donc l'idée d'en vie
c'était de de détourner les codes et les
couleurs du black friday pour
sensibiliser le public à modes de
consommation alternatif différent plus
respectueux de l'environnement plus
solidaire aussi fait parler de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
donc ces trois jours là seront
l'occasion de montrer que d'autres modes
de consommation sont possibles donc
trois jours qui se dérouleront à trappes
en magasin ou via d'autres à plusieurs
animations proposées vous incitez
notamment les personnes à venir apporter
pendant ces trois jours pas que c'est
pendant ces trois jours mais vous
incitez particulière sur ce green faille
des rats les personnes à porter leurs
vieux objets leurs vieux matériel
électroménager
oui exactement
le principe encore une fois c'est de
participer à cette économie circulaire
que l'on veut promouvoir
donc les gens seront récompensés
d'ailleurs de ce geste cela par des bons
d'achat mais là aussi on se se distingue
du black friday puisque ils pourront
utiliser quand ils le voudront donc au
moment où ils le voudront il s'agit pas
de céder à l'impulsion d'un achat
immédiat parce que prix intéressant si
vous avez besoin d'un lave linge dans
deux ans ou d'un réfrigérateur dans
quatre ans vous pourrez utiliser bon
dans deux ans dans quatre ans notamment
au programme aussi et demain et vendredi
à des ateliers de réparation d'appareils
électroménagers c'est pas trop difficile
à remettre en route des appareils
électroménagers
ça peut ça peut être compliqué mais je
n'ai cessé c'est c'est des métiers
techniques
c'est pour ça que ce sont des vrais
professionnels qui les enseignes hausse
à nos ateliers
mais là on va vouloir montrer au grand
public des petits conseils des astuces
assez simple pour pouvoir se dépanner
soi même il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
peut faire sans faire appel à un
professionnel il ya d'autres il faudra
faire appel à des pros mais ça c'est
l'idée et puis on lance aussi ça c'est
un petit clin d'oeil
avery solidaire on est très solidaire
exactement pendant deux jours donc
demain et après demain
les gens pourront venir laver sécher
leur linge dans nos ateliers qu'on
transforme en laverie gratuite et
ouverte à tous c'est aussi une façon
pour nous de lancer une réflexion sur
l'économie d'usagé et donc de trouver
des alternatives aux consommation à
outrance
dernière chose il ya des visites
d'ateliers également au programme sa
visite d'atelier l'idée est vraiment
encore une fois de sensibiliser publica
à l'économie circulaire à la réparation
est aussi
en profiter pour montrer qu'elle est
notre travail d'insertion
professionnelle puisque là encore c'est
quelque chose auquel on est très attaché
c'est au coeur de notre métier c'est
l'accompagnement de personnes qui
étaient en difficulté vis-à-vis du monde
de travail pour les remettre dans
l'emploi donc ce sera l'occasion
d'échanger avec le public et en parler
largement merci eric gastineau d'abord
est avec nous merci à vous je rappelle
le directeur du magasin en ville de
trappes et le green friday c'est de
demain à samedi plus d'informations sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
le sport ils étaient plus de deux mille
cinq cents élèves au départ de lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines le
cross départemental de l'urss 78 se
tenait cet après-midi un trou figeac
hauts-de-seine ce qualificatif pour le
cross de l'académie de versailles une
compétition 100% mixte et par équipes 9
catégories étaient en lice des benjamins
aux seniors avec des courses sur des
distances allant de 1700 à 4000 m
interview collectées au micro de nicolas
landry l'objectif de ces compétitions
c'est c'est tout d'abord permettre au
plus grand nombre déjà de pratiquer du
sport 1
donc au delà de l'aspect qualification
on est surtout dans une grande fête du
sport c'est permettent à tous les élèves
de pratiquer la course à pied
permettre aux élèves en fait de se
dépenser et d'être dans l'activité
physique afin de passer un bon moment
ensemble
c'est le résultat d'un récent sondage de
tns sofres y parents sur dix en france
proposent à leurs enfants des livres
qu'ils ont aimé durant leur enfance et
donner le goût à de la lecture aux plus
petits c'est tout l'objectif de cette
association est lire et faire lire
mais ce n'est pas que ça il ya aussi
d'autres missions va voir ça avec jérôme
morin bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
bénévoles de cette association dans les
yvelines à lire et faire lire alors
l'objectif est double derrière c'est
bien sûr de donner le goût de la
littérature de la lecture aux enfants
mais aussi à l'idée derrière de
développer le lien entre les générations
les deux les deux le goût de la
littérature jeunesse
oui et puis le fait que ce soit des
grands parents des gens de plus de 50
ans ça leur montre que plus longtemps
après avoir été ou après avoir été actif
on peut continuer à transmettre quelque
chose et à exister
c'est le principe c'est que c'est
ferrand des lecteurs bénévoles seniors
qui vont se rendre dans des écoles dans
d'autres structures pour regarder écoles
des crèches et les maternelles des
collèges aussi l'initiative lire et
faire lire est remonte à assez loin
c'est ça c'est 1999 l'écrivain alexandre
jardin qui est qu'il a lancé en 1999
alexandre jardin a eu connaissance d'un
procédés analogues qui se passait à
brest et il a voulu le développer
ensuite et ça a démarré
l'association a démarré en 2000 donc
l'association est bien présente dans les
abîmes plus 300 bénévoles 3 6 bénévoles
dans les yvelines pourrait y en avoir
plus mais principalement dans les zones
urbaines sartrouville conflent
rambouillet versailles
saint-germain-en-laye et pas est passé
dans les zones rurales
c est ce qui manque encore peut-être et
une présence est plus difficile que les
écoles le demander que et qui est des
bénévoles
c'est ce que vous me disiez tout à
l'heure en off avant cette interview
c'est finalement un département comme
les hauts de seine qui est plus petit
géographiquement que les élus n'a plus
de à plus de bénévoles
oui mais c'est beaucoup plus urbain dont
jouit tout saisi aussi une identité qui
fait qu' il ya plus de deux possibilités
alors dans un monde où les écrans se
multiplient où les enfants vont plus
volontiers vers la tablette et ses
applications qu'elles aient finalement
l'importance à vos yeux de donner le
goût de cette lecture aux plus petits ça
incite à l'activité appuyé sur une
tablette c'est facile et puis les
pachtouns taux de sol alors qu'elle ait
cherché un livre tourner les pages le
prendre l'emporter avec soi et un livre
ça du volume c'est un volume alors
qu'une tablette on peut en mettre
plusieurs dedans et ça n'a plus de
volume mais donc ça incite à l'activité
jusqu'à la passivité et finalement on
est devant une machine mais oui l'idée
aussi comme il ya ces seniors qui lisent
ces livres c'est qu'il ya un il ya aussi
un côté de tendresse entre les entre les
enfants et les personnes âgées
oui en plus quand on quand on lit le
livre on le joue le livre on ne lit pas
donc ça ça montre le plaisir qui peut y
avoir avoir un livre entre les mains et
à s'en servir et à le faire vivre
il a d'ailleurs on voit un des clips
promotionnels ou les bénévoles
n'hésitent pas à donner à se prendre des
acteurs pour eux pour essayer de se
compter les livres alors vous êtes
bénévole
jérôme maurin depuis 2002 au sein de
lire et faire lire
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé dans cette
démarche j'avais le souvenir que ma mère
nous lisait je me souvenir des inscrits
de laubarède libre de deux voyages
extraordinaires de fin du 19e siècle
comique livre comique un livre
d'histoire elle nous a aussi lu les
histoires des musiciens donc ça elle
nous lisait et moi j'ai voulu continuer
7,7 ce transfert cette transmission
point c'était quelque chose qui vous a
plu vous petit c'est important de très
important de transmettre compter les
autres et puis quand on arrive un moment
où on a plus d'activité parce qu'on est
en retraite doivent retrouver un emploi
du temps est celui là ça me convenait et
les enfants sont demandeurs et les aime
ces lectures
écoutez quand j'arrive dans les
différents sites où je fais la lecture
oui ils viennent ils sont au coût c'est
c'est bon c'est agréable et ça quand
j'en ressors après une séance on est
dopé
moi je fais ça pour moi c'est sa porte
quelqu'un savait quelque chose là
quelque chose
les changes qui a eut été très positif
alors comment se déroule justement une
séance ça se passe par petits groupes
ces lectures c'est ça au nahd et des
groupes de six enfants
enfin maximum 6 500 ce qu'on trouve
considère comme étant là
la bonne cote et puis bon ça dépend des
endroits où je vais dans un foyer
d'accueil les enfants ils sont dans le
jeu retrouvent dans la salle où ils sont
je vais dans une école c'est pendant ils
viennent de la cour de récréation ils me
voient arriver où seule une clause 8
ils arrivent ils savent que je vais être
là ils viennent et puis nous emmène dans
une salle puis on choisit de livres j'en
ai un paquet je ne vois plus que je plus
que de raison mais je choisis sous ou
six mois qui choisit ça dépend du jour
mais souvent ils aiment bien choisir un
peu réservé leurs mots à dire
et retrouver les mêmes il ya une
sélection par tranche d'âge aussi peut
être des livres première enfance au
début des choses un peu plus je lis
principalement à des cp ce1 donc c'est
ça à peu près c'est cohérent comme eux
mais je sais qu il ya effectivement des
choix en fonction des âges qu'il faut
faire dans les albums dans l'est dans
les livres qu'on manipule pour reprendre
le toucher pour apprendre les sensations
pour ça dépend de l'âge des ambitions et
de l'est leur besoin et ça on arrive à
le déterminer
dernière chose on disait il reste 30
secondes environ 300 bénévoles pour lire
et faire lire dans le monde dans les
yvelines
là vous êtes en vous êtes en recherche
constante ça fait du bien d'en avoir
plus ça serait bien ce serait bien d'en
avoir plus écoutées en tout cas vous
pouvez si vous souhaitez plus
d'informations
peut-être devenir bénévoles de cette
association vous rendre sur le site
internet celle lire et faire lire point
org ça s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
du robot un merci d'avoir été avec nous
est le bénévole de lire et faire lire
dans les yvelines avant de refermer ce
journal une véritable guerre se joue en
ce moment à versailles c'est jusqu'au 26
novembre
un opéra comique mise en scène par jean
philippe di russo une oeuvre pour
célébrer les deux cent quarante ans du
théâtre montansier camille lambert et
marie pannetrat
un humour burlesque des chants et des
marionnettes utilisées pour se moquer
des genres théâtraux au xviiie siècle
les forains commentait déjà l'actualité
théâtrale avec l'opéra comique à une
moquerie sur la grandiloquence de
certains genres par exemple on
caricature la comédie française dans ce
qu'elle a de plus outré de plus larges
dans ses références à la tragédie
antique et ses caricatures l'opéra qui
focalisent sur des mots alors qu'elle
est en train de parler
la serrure vocalises sur une voyelle et
on voit les pauvres sera se moquait
aussi deux de ces gens là la guerre des
théâtres oeuvre au cadre historique
raconte l'histoire de forains jouant la
matrone d'ephèse jalouse la comédie
française vient interrompre la pièce et
l'opéra vise à interdire le champ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une métaphore des guerres de théâtre à
cette période
tous les genres sont présents pantomime
opéra marionnettes et théâtre
un mélange acquis dès le xviiie siècle
c'est justement la force des comédiens
forains leur force leur imagination leur
inventivité pour contrer les
interdictions exercée par la colonie
française et l'opéra qui ont permis de
créer ce théâtre qu'on aimerait
aujourd'hui hybride la pièce plonge les
spectateurs dans le passé les décors
sont d'époque pas en 1836 par six séries
et boulay et l'éclairage fidèle aux
coutumes d'antan
pour compléter cette ambiance les
spectateurs peuvent venir habillés avec
des costumes d'époque
jusqu'au 26 novembre au théâtre
montansier à versailles
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal à ne
pas manquer ce soir dans sept huit
culture mélanie poker vous dévoilera le
prix du public et du festival saint
quentin du film documentaire
quant à ce journal vous pouvez bien sûr
le retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]